We'll call this guy Chris. He had a job as a middleman, but a kind of odd sort of middleman.
我们叫这个家伙克里斯。他以前从事中介工作，但是一种很奇特的中介。
We basically are the middleman between the deaf and someone who can hear.
我们基本上是聋人和听力正常人之间的中间人。
Chris worked for a company that helped deaf people communicate over the telephone. To make a call, a deaf person would contact Chris. He would get the hearing person on the line. The deaf person would type what it is that they wanted to say. Chris would read this to the hearing person, and then type their responses back to the deaf person. Most of the conversations were what you'd expect: people calling their families, talking about what they had for dinner, calling their banks.
克里斯在一家帮助聋人通过电话进行交流的公司工作。如果聋人想打电话，他们会联系克里斯。克里斯会拨通对方的电话，让听力正常的人接听。聋人会打字写下他们想说的话，克里斯会读给对方听，然后把对方的回答打字传回给聋人。大多数对话都在意料之中：人们给家人打电话，谈论晚餐吃了什么，给银行打电话。
And then again, because I usually worked nights, some of the calls were very intimate phone conversations between people breaking up, people just falling in love for the first time, people telling them that members of their family had died, phone sex, things no one would ever want you to hear, really.
话虽如此，因为我通常上夜班，有些电话是非常私密的通话，比如情侣分手、第一次坠入爱河、告诉家人亲属过世的消息、电话性爱等等，真的，这些都是别人绝不希望你听到的事情。
One thing that happened more often than you'd think, especially when parents were talking to their kids, is that they would get into an argument, and then one of them would try to drag Chris into the argument on their side of it.
有一件事发生的频率比你想象的要高得多，尤其是在父母与孩子交谈时，他们会发生争执，然后其中一方会试图把克里斯拉进争执中，站到他们那边。
And I wasn't allowed to say anything, so I would just say, the CA, we're co-communication assistants, does not have that information. That was the blanket phrase that they let me use.
我被规定不能发表意见，所以我通常会说，CA，也就是沟通辅助员，没有这方面的信息。这就是他们让我使用的万能回应。
That's so computer-like.
那听起来太像计算机了。
Well, that was the paradigm they wanted us to follow. They wanted us to be computers, basically, information machines. I remember a daughter had been, it was a deaf daughter, and she had been out sleeping around and doing a lot of drugs, evidently. And the mother was just trying to tell her that she needed to stop doing all these things and saying, "You may feel like you're young, and you can just do what you want, and since you're deaf, you feel you have an excuse to do all these things."
嗯，那就是他们希望我们遵循的模式。他们基本上希望我们成为计算机，成为信息机器。我记得有个聋人女儿，显然她一直在外面乱搞，还吸食大量毒品。母亲只是试图告诉她需要停止这些行为，说：“你可能觉得你还年轻，可以随心所欲，而且因为你是聋人，你就觉得你有借口做这些事。”
And she started talking to me, and she said, "You don't do drugs, do you?" And I said, the CA does not have that information. And then she said, "Well, can't you just type to her and tell her that you think she's hurting herself as well?"
她开始跟我说话，她说：“你没吸毒，对吧？”我说，CA没有这方面的信息。然后她说：“好吧，那你不能直接打字告诉她，你也认为她在伤害自己吗？”
Now when she's saying this to you, do you have to type that in, so the daughter knows that she's saying it to you?
现在，当她对你说这些话时，你必须把这些打出来，让那个女儿知道她在对你说这些话吗？
Yeah, you do. You have to type everything that she's saying. The daughter really disliked that. The daughter would start talking to me and say, "Don't let her talk to you." And she would start trying to tell me just how terrible the mother had been to her growing up. The mother actually said at this point, "This is really embarrassing," and tried to pretend like I wasn't there the rest of the time.
是的，必须。你必须打出她说的每一句话。那个女儿真的很讨厌这样。女儿开始跟我说：“别让她跟你说话。”她还试图告诉我，她母亲在她的成长过程中有多么糟糕。母亲这时说：“这真的很尴尬，”并试图假装我在其余时间都不存在。
It's hard to be the middleman. Pizza delivery places always hung up on Chris and the other operators. Phone sex operators and drug dealers were way more service-oriented when it came to the deaf. And then there were the people who liked to mess with the middleman, like two African-American guys one day, who started using all sorts of words and phrases just because it would be funny to hear the white operator say them.
做中间人很难。披萨店总是挂断克里斯和其他接线员的电话。在对待聋人方面，电话性爱接线员和毒贩的服务意识要强得多。还有一些人喜欢捉弄中间人，比如有一天两个非裔美国人，他们开始使用各种词汇和短语，只是觉得听白人接线员说这些话会很有趣。
They were talking in really heavy street slang. One person was intent on having me use the n-word, over and over. And it was very uncomfortable. But the two people using it on the phone obviously didn't care. They just wanted to have me do it.
他们用非常浓重的街头俚语交谈。其中一个人一心想让我反复使用那个歧视黑人的词。这非常令人不安。但在电话里使用这个词的两个人显然不在乎。他们只是想让我说出口。
And they were even joking about me doing it. They would just be laughing. A lot of people find a lot of amusement out of playing with a Communication Assistant. I found it kind of funny after a while.
他们甚至拿我这么做来开玩笑。他们只是在那儿大笑。很多人从戏弄沟通辅助员中找到了乐趣。过了一段时间，我也觉得这有点滑稽。
All of my friends who went through the training for this were young black women. And they thought I was kind of really straight. And they used to perk their ears up immediately as soon as they heard me get into any sort of ghetto speak, or whatnot.
所有和我一起接受这项培训的朋友都是年轻的黑人女性。她们觉得我非常“正经”。只要她们听到我用任何一种贫民窟的口吻说话，她们就会立刻竖起耳朵。
Because I can't do it. I didn't like it. But I wasn't going to read in a completely white bread tone of voice, either. I didn't want to do that. It was humiliating and funny at the same time.
因为我做不到。我不喜欢那样。但我也不想用一种完全“纯白”的语调去读。我不想那样做。这既令人羞辱又令人觉得滑稽。
Give another example of times it was hard just to be an information machine.
再举个例子，说说作为一台信息机器有多难。
A man actually had just fallen off a ladder in his garage. And he had gone deaf. And so he was calling up all his friends and telling them what had happened to him. And so these people were completely unfamiliar with the service.
有个男人刚从车库的梯子上摔下来。他失聪了。所以他给所有朋友打电话，告诉他们发生了什么事。而这些人对这项服务完全陌生。
So I had to explain the service. They still didn't understand it. And then he had to tell them, explain what the service was, why he was using it, and how he had just gone deaf.
所以我不得不解释这项服务。他们还是不理解。然后他不得不告诉他们，解释这项服务是什么，为什么要使用它，以及他刚是如何失聪的。
And it was very obvious, I remember one man he had called, they were not that close. And the man obviously did not know how to react. He was having a really hard time. He just kept saying I'm sorry, over and over. And it was really excessive. And it was just really hard to keep telling all of it, knowing that you're going to have to tell six or seven people after this that this man has gone deaf.
显而易见，我记得他打给的一个人，他们关系并不亲近。那个人显然不知道该如何反应。他表现得非常痛苦。他只是不停地说抱歉，一遍又一遍。这真的太夸张了。在知道接下来还要告诉六七个人这个男人失聪的消息时，还要一直复述这些，真的太难了。
And at the end of that, so now you as a person, you've been through this experience with him of now, the two of you have told a half dozen people that he's gone deaf. It must be hard that after you get off the phone with the last person, that you and he don't talk about what just happened.
在这之后，作为一个人，你和他一起经历了这件事，你们两个人告诉了六个人他失聪的消息。在与最后一个人通话结束后，你们两人却不能谈论刚才发生的事，这一定很难受吧。
Right. Sometimes people will say, because there is a 30-second window of time where I'm still on the line with him. I remember he typed, "Thank you so much. I'm sure that must have been very hard for you as well as me." So there is a brief moment of time.
没错。有时候人们会说，因为我有30秒的时间还在线上陪着他。我记得他打字说：“非常感谢你。我相信这对你来说一定和我一样难受。”所以确实有那么短暂的一刻。
It's hard to be the middleman. It's hard to keep your feelings out of it. It hard to stay neutral. People want you to get involved, and they want you to get out of it. You can't win for losing. And I say this as a middle child.
做中间人很难。很难让自己置身事外。很难保持中立。人们希望你参与其中，又希望你别插手。怎么做都不对。我是家里的老二，所以我深有体会。
And there there's that whole "eliminate the middleman" thing, eliminate the middleman. If you Google the phrase "eliminate the middleman," you get 3,800 websites promising to eliminate middlemen of every kind for you, car dealers, realtors, stockbrokers, furniture stores, stamp sales, plus one site that has figured out a way to bypass the lousy crop of presidential candidates we're offered every four years. Eliminate the middleman, it promises. Satan for President in 2004.
还有那种所谓的“消灭中间人”的说法。如果你在谷歌上搜索“消灭中间人”这个短语，你会找到3800个网站，承诺为你消灭各种中间人：汽车经销商、房地产经纪人、股票经纪人、家具店、邮票销售商，还有一个网站想出了绕过我们每四年都要面对的那一堆糟糕总统候选人的办法。消灭中间人，它承诺道。2004年选撒旦当总统。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Today on our program, middlemen. We will not eliminate him. We will not pass the savings on to you. No, no, no, for once, a defense of the beleaguered middleman in three acts, including a simple explanation of how you, yes, you, could have gotten rich off Michael Jordan, using the simple rules of market economics and a good down parka. Stay with us.
好了，这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。今天节目的主题是：中间人。我们不会消灭他。我们不会把节省下来的钱转让给你。不，不，不，这一次，我们要为处境艰难的中间人辩护，节目分三幕进行，包括一个简单的解释，告诉你——没错，就是你——如何利用市场经济的简单规则和一件好的防寒派克大衣，从迈克尔·乔丹身上发财。留下来吧。
Act One, Show Me the Monet. You know, you can't do a story about middlemen without a story about business and all the people who make their livings buying low and selling high, how they are sort of looking out for their customers, and sort of looking out for their product and their suppliers, and mainly looking out for themselves. And this story begins, as so many radio stories seem to these days, with a classifieds ad.
第一幕，给我看莫奈。你知道，如果不讲关于生意、不讲那些靠低买高卖为生的人，就做不成关于中间人的故事。他们如何在某种程度上照顾顾客，在某种程度上照顾产品和供应商，主要是照顾他们自己。这个故事，就像最近很多广播故事一样，从一则分类广告开始。
Triple-A tickets, all events, seven days, concerts, sports, theater, Lincoln Park. And then it's got the address and the phone number. For a lot of years, I worked here. And if someone had called this ad, called in the phone number here, I probably would have been the one to answer the phone.
AAA门票，所有活动，七天，音乐会，体育，戏剧，林肯公园。然后是地址和电话号码。我在这里工作了很多年。如果有人打了这则广告上的电话，打到了这里，接电话的人很可能就是我。
When people call this number, I don't know what kind of place they're imagining, maybe a fancy little office downtown. But we were actually in the back of a video store, in this little dark office, the ceiling fan going real slowly counter-clockwise, kind of squeaking, one beam of light coming through the tall window up top, and dust streaming around the room, and a dog's barking out back. I remember, for a while, there was not many movies on the shelves. There was Buster, that movie that Phil Collins made.
当人们拨打这个号码时，我不知道他们想象的是什么样的地方，也许是市中心一间精致的小办公室。但实际上我们是在一家录像带店的后面，在一个昏暗的小办公室里，吊扇很慢地逆时针转动，发出吱吱声，一束光从顶上的高窗透进来，灰尘在房间里飘荡，后院还有狗在叫。我记得有一段时间，货架上的电影不多。有一部叫《巴斯特》的电影，是菲尔·柯林斯拍的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And no one would ever rent those movies.
而且根本没人会租那些电影。
How long did you work there?
你在那儿干了多久？
On and off from '96 to about 2001. Over the course of those few years, I got to know the ticket world inside and out. I met people with names like 35th Street Eddie, South Side Frank, Fast Willie, Richie the Head. There was a guy named Elbow, who had sort of a big elbow.
从96年到2001年左右，断断续续干了几年。在那几年里，我对票务圈了如指掌。我遇到了像35街埃迪、南区弗兰克、快手威利、头儿里奇这样的人。还有个叫“肘子”的人，因为他的肘关节特别大。
A lot of guys got nicknames after whatever event that they specialized in, Monet Joe. One time, there was a Monet exhibit at the art institute. So people come in from out of town, and they want to go to the exhibit. The only way they can go is if they have these VIP staff passes.
很多人是以他们专攻的活动来起绰号的，比如莫奈·乔。有一次，艺术学院有一个莫奈展览。人们从外地赶来，想去看展览。他们能进去的唯一办法就是拥有这些贵宾员工通行证。
And Monet somehow managed to have a few hundred of them. All the ticket brokers, all the ticket guys, all the hotel concierges, everyone was calling Monet. And from then on, he's just been called Monet.
莫奈不知怎么地弄到了几百张。所有的票务经纪人、所有的票务商、所有的酒店礼宾部，每个人都在给莫奈打电话。从那以后，他就一直被称为莫奈。
So you came back to town and started to look up some of the people that you used to work with, right? And so who did you talk to first?
所以你回到城里，开始联系一些你以前的同事，对吧？那么你先和谁谈了？
First, I looked up an old ticket friend named Liz. And we started talking about some of our old clients.
首先，我联系了一位老票务朋友莉兹。我们开始谈论我们的一些老客户。
You spends so much time on the phone talking to the worst people. They're either mean, or they're rude. Ugh. And you're always putting people on hold, like, "Let me get my supervisor. Let me talk to my supervisor." And you're like, ptth. I'm not doing [BLEEP] for this guy. He stayed on hold. He'll hang up. He'll hang up.
你花那么多时间在电话里和最糟糕的人交谈。他们要么很刻薄，要么很粗鲁。额。你总是让人们等待，比如，“让我去找我的主管。让我和我的主管谈谈。”而你会想，呸。我才不会为这家伙做任何事呢。让他等着。他会挂断的。他会挂断的。
We call it the stew pot. When you left someone just on hold, you say let them stew for a  little while. And usually, if they're kind of hemming and hawing, going back and forth, you let them stew for a few, like five minutes. Maybe come on once and be like, "Hang in there, man. Hang in there. I'll be right back with you." Let them stew another five minutes. Then, after 10, they're ready to talk. They're ready to deal.
我们称之为“炖锅”。当你把某人晾在一边等待时，你说让他们炖一会儿。通常如果他们犹豫不决，反复推脱，你就让他们炖一会儿，比如五分钟。也许偶尔上线说一下：“坚持住，伙计。坚持住。我马上回来。”让他们再炖五分钟。然后十分钟后，他们就准备好谈话了。他们准备好交易了。
Yeah, definitely. We had the lead transfer him to this line that would ring and ring and ring. You're like, "Don't pick up line four. Everybody knows line four is [BLEEP] line. Don't pick it up."
是啊，绝对的。我们会让主管把他们转到那条会一直响一直响的线路上。你会想，“别接四号线。每个人都知道四号线是烂线。别接。”
That's so funny, because we always had the same thing. We had different lines that meant different things. You had a couple lines you had to answer different things. Like one line, you had to answer, hello. Like any time we try to get act tickets through legitimate means, like group sales or anything like that. You would put the home phone number. So it said on all the phones, hello. There was a little taped-up piece of paper that said "hello" on it to remind you to answer it "hello?"
真搞笑，因为我们也总是遇到同样的情况。我们有不同的线路，意味着不同的含义。你有几条线路必须以不同的方式接听。比如有一条线，你必须接听时说“喂”。比如任何时候我们试图通过正规渠道获得门票时，比如团体预订之类的。你会填写家庭电话号码。所以所有电话上都写着“喂”。上面贴着一张小纸条，写着“喂”来提醒你接听时要说“喂？”。
This was a phone line that was supposed to simulate an actual home, someone's residence. You were just supposed to pick it up and say, "Hello?" This was when we ordered group sale tickets from the Cubs. So we put in orders for tons of group sales. And if they knew we were a ticket broker, they wouldn't be having it. We wouldn't get the tickets. So we'd pick different names of organizations.
这是一条模拟真实家庭住宅的电话线。你只需要接起来说“喂？”。这是我们从小熊队订团体票的时候。所以我们预订了大量的团体票。如果他们知道我们是票务经纪人，他们就不会卖给我们了。我们买不到票。所以我们会用不同组织的名字。
They actually would check, though?
他们真的会核实吗？
No, they would just call you. And they would be like, what's the name of your organization? And sometimes you would say, "Oh, well, it's Grandpa Louie's 70th birthday. So we're bringing 40 people to that game." Or, "The Little League hockey team that I coach, we're having a special slumber party. And we need 120 tickets. We got tykes coming from all over, up and down the state. They're all-stars. You should see some of these kids. They're really fine hockey players."
不，他们只会打电话给你。他们会问，你们组织的名字是什么？有时候你会说：“哦，那是路易爷爷的70岁生日。所以我们要带40个人去那场比赛。”或者，“我执教的小联盟曲棍球队，我们要举行一个特别的睡衣派对。我们需要120张票。我们从州里四面八方找来了小球员。他们都是全明星。你应该看看这些孩子，他们是真正出色的曲棍球运动员。”
There was another phone line that if it rang, you were just supposed to pick the phone line up and not say anything at all, just pick it up and put it to your ear and be silent. That was Guy Lobster, who owned the business. That was one of his special lines. And it was important that just didn't say anything. You weren't supposed to let them hear your voice, even. So just pick it up and be silent. Actually, I never figured out what that one was for.
还有另一条电话线，如果它响了，你只需要接起电话，什么都不要说，接起来放在耳边保持安静就行。那是盖伊·龙虾的线，他是老板。那是他的一条特殊线路。重要的是绝对不要说话。你不应该让他们听到你的声音。所以只需要接起来保持沉默。说实话，我从来没弄明白那条线是干嘛的。
There's a guy named Leo, who was one of my best friends of all the ticket guys. And a couple days ago, I was in Ann Arbor, at a Michigan football game, and Leo was out there, buying and selling. I saw a couple of the old guys I knew, so they'd come in from all over. And Leo was out there. So I put this mic on his collar, attached the battery pack to his butt, and just listened to him walk around.
有个叫里奥的家伙，他是我所有票务朋友中最好的一个。几天前，我在安娜堡看一场密歇根大学的足球赛，里奥也在那儿，忙着买进卖出。我看到了几个我认识的老伙计，他们从四面八方赶来。里奥也在那儿。于是我把麦克风夹在他的领子上，把电池包别在他的屁股上，然后就听他在周围走动。
Anybody got one extra ticket? Anybody got one extra?
有人有多余的票吗？有人有多余的吗？
What is this called, actually, what he's doing now? Is there a term for what he's doing?
这叫什么，他现在在做什么？他所做的有没有一个术语？
Yeah, he's walking the walk. The area by the stadium or by the concert hall is called the walk. And then you're walking the walk. You're saying, "Who needs two?"
有，他在“走秀”。体育场或音乐厅旁边的区域被称为“秀场”。你就是在“走秀”。你在说：“谁需要两张？”
So he's just showed up here without any tickets.
所以他就这样空着手出现在这儿了？
Right. He's trying to buy some tickets, so then he can turn them around, and, we say "flip 'em," so he can flip  them for some dough, flip them for a profit.
没错。他想买一些票，然后把它们转手卖掉，我们称之为“翻倍卖”，这样他就能赚点钱，翻倍赚取利润。
You got one extra? How much do you want for it? 20?
你有多余的一张吗？你想要多少？20？
We're at row 60.
我们是在第60排。
Row 60? How about 15?
第60排？15怎么样？
How about 20?
20怎么样？
20?
20？
Yeah.
是啊。
18?
18？
$49 ticket.
49美元的票。
OK. Sure you can't do 15?
好的。确定不能15吗？
I'll do 18, but that's it.
我可以做18，但就这么多。
There you go.
给你。
Got it. Thanks.
拿到了。谢谢。
Thanks.
谢谢。
OK, so I actually timed this. From the moment he says "Thank you, man," to the moment he runs into another person is exactly 1 minute and 20 seconds.
好了，我特意计时了。从他说“谢谢你，伙计”到他遇到下一个人，正好是1分20秒。
You guys need tickets? I got one. I'd sell it for 100.
你们需要票吗？我有一张。我卖100。
You'd sell it for 100? Yeah, midfield.
你卖100？是啊，中场位置。
We ain't got that--
我们没有那么多--
Wait a minute. He just tried to sell it for $100?
等一下。他刚才试着卖100美元？
You get what you can, you know? You might as well start high. You never know. Maybe the guy's going to pull out $100 and say, here. It can't hurt to start at $100 and come down.
你能拿到多少就是多少，你知道吗？你最好一开始就报高价。谁知道呢。也许那家伙会掏出100美元说，给你。一开始报100美元再降价不会有什么坏处。
You can't go up. You can't say $30, and if the guy says, "Only 30?" Be, "Oh, no, no, no. 50." Start as high-- you can always come down.
你不能往上报。你不能报30美元，如果对方说，“才30？”然后说，“哦，不，不，不。50。”一开始就报高价——你总是可以降价的。
Did you have other techniques that you used when you were doing this?
当你做这个的时候，你还有其他使用的技巧吗？
There's a whole psychology to what to do to sell someone tickets. Like when I was on the street, outside of the United Center, say, at a Bulls game, I'd present myself differently to different people, depending on what I thought they wanted out of this ticket-buying transaction. Some guys would be kind of nervous. And I'd see him walking up, and all the hustlers going up to him, trying to sell him tickets. And they'd look all wary. And they'd have a couple kids with them.
卖票给别人有一整套心理学。比如当我在街上，在联合中心外面，比如在公牛队的比赛时，我会根据我认为他们想从这次购票交易中得到什么，而以不同的方式展现自己。有些人会很紧张。我看到他走过来，所有的拉皮条的人都围上去，试图卖票给他。他们看起来很警惕。他们还带着几个孩子。
So then I'd go up to them, and I'd just be like, "Sir, my uncle couldn't come to the game tonight. But I do have this extra ticket, if you guys want to come. They're great seats. I sit in them every game with my uncle." And I made him feel comfortable buying tickets from me.
所以我走过去，我会说：“先生，我叔叔今晚不能来看比赛了。但我确实有一张多余的票，如果你们想来的话。位置很好。我每场比赛都和叔叔一起坐那儿。”我让他觉得从我这里买票很舒服。
And sometimes, there were the guys who, they'd come with a few friends. And they wanted to show off that they could work with our underworld element, that they knew how to deal with scalpers. They'd be like, "I'll take care of it." They'd say to their friends, you'd see them, "I'll be right back." And they'd come up to me.
有时候，还有些家伙和几个朋友一起来。他们想炫耀自己能和我们这些地下势力打交道，他们知道怎么应付黄牛。他们会说：“这事儿我搞定。”你会看到他们对朋友说，“我一会儿就回来。”然后他们会走过来找我。
And then I'd be the hardened street hustler. And I'd be looking around constantly. I'd be saying, "Come on, man. The heat's tight out here tonight. Work with me. Work with me. What are you payin'? What are you payin'? What do you need?" Just trying to make them feel like they were really wheeling and dealing.
然后我会扮演强硬的街头混混。我会不断地环顾四周。我会说：“快点，伙计。今晚管得严。跟我配合好。跟我配合好。你付多少？你付多少？你需要什么？”只是想让他们觉得他们真的在进行一场重大交易。
Did you always win? Did the customer ever have a chance?
你总是赢吗？顾客有机会吗？
Really, out of every transaction, both people win. If they paid you it, then they could afford it. So many people would buy tickets from me at just what I imagine to be an exorbitant-- I myself was like, this price is ridiculous. And yet, they would be so happy. They would be glowing. And they were so appreciative and thankful to me, for getting them into the game.
说实话，每一笔交易，双方都是赢家。如果他们付了钱，说明他们负担得起。很多人以我看来极其昂贵的价格从我这儿买票——我自己都觉得这价格简直荒谬。然而，他们会非常开心。他们会容光焕发。他们非常感激我能让他们进入球场。
But I did make it a rule, sometimes a point of pride, to not let them go in with any, you know, to see how much money they had in their wallet. And I was going to take all of it. They didn't need popcorn in the game. They didn't need a beer.
但我确实制定了一条规则，有时是一种自尊心，不让他们进去时口袋里还剩什么钱。我要把钱全拿走。他们在球场里不需要爆米花，也不需要啤酒。
Being a ticket broker is different than being in other businesses, where if you run a bar, and you run out of Bud Lite, you call up and have them pull that truck right up out back in the loading dock and wheel about 20 cases off. But when you want to get tickets, it's not that simple. There's no easy way to do it. So ticket brokers have to rely on just a whole network of shadowy associates to bring the tickets into them.
做票务经纪人不同于其他生意。如果你开了一家酒吧，百威淡啤卖完了，你可以打个电话让卡车开到卸货平台，卸下20箱。但当你想要票时，没那么简单。没有简单的方法。所以票务经纪人必须依靠一整套阴影里的关系网把票搞到手。
There's a guy named Moose who has a whole bike gang. And every year, when Cubs games would go on sale, at the Cubs on sale, you're only allowed to buy eight tickets for up to eight games, so 64 tickets total. He would get about 15 of his biker friends. He would just keep them up all night on Friday night drinking, merrymaking, singing, whatever it would take.
有个叫穆斯的家伙，他有一个完整的摩托帮。每年，当小熊队门票开售时，小熊队规定每人最多只能买八场比赛的八张票，总共64张。他会找大约15个骑摩托车的朋友。他会在周五晚上整晚让他们喝酒、狂欢、唱歌，不管用什么手段。
So when the tickets went on sale, he'd then have 15 guys who were waiting there. And hopefully the weren't passed out. They were waiting there to buy 64 tickets each. When he brings them in to the ticket broker, the broker will pay him $10 over the face value for each ticket.
所以当票开售时，他就会有15个人在那儿等着。希望他们没喝醉。他们在那里等着每人买64张票。当他把票带给票务经纪人时，经纪人会为每张票支付比面值高出10美元的价格。
At the Bulls on sales, they started doing this lottery system. They didn't want people to just be camping out two weeks beforehand, because they knew that these tickets were going to be worth so much. So a couple enterprising ticket brokers started rounding up the homeless guys around Chicago.
在公牛队开售时，他们开始实行这种抽签系统。他们不想让人在两周前就露宿街头，因为他们知道这些票价值连城。于是几个投机取巧的票务经纪人开始在芝加哥周围搜罗无家可归者。
The actually would rent a school bus, and they would drive around Chicago, just pulling people into the bus, promising them $10 or $20 if they'd come hang out for the morning. Sometimes they'd even pull up in front of the homeless shelter right down there on South Wabash or South State and just toot the horn. And all the guys would come filing out and fill up the bus.
他们实际上会租一辆校车，然后在芝加哥到处开，把人拉上车，承诺给他们10美元或20美元，让他们在早上过来排队。有时候他们甚至会停在南沃巴什或南州街的流浪汉收容所门前，按响喇叭。然后所有人都会排队出来，坐满那辆车。
They'd drive them down to the United Center box office window. When the tickets went on sale, you'd have, out of the first 60 people in line, there'd be 50 homeless guys waiting to buy these $100 tickets. And the brokers would just give them a few hundred bucks each to buy the tickets they wanted.
他们把他们拉到联合中心的售票窗口。当票开售时，排在前60个人里，会有50个流浪汉等着买这些100美元的门票。经纪人只会给他们每人几百美元，让他们买他们想要的票。
Every once in a while, tickets would be released into the system. Suddenly they would become available. A game that had been sold out, suddenly there are six tickets that are available. And maybe it's a season ticket holder who has canceled, and said, "I can't come to this game."
每隔一段时间，门票会被释放进系统。突然之间它们就可以买了。一场本来已经售罄的比赛，突然有六张票可以买了。也许是一个季票持有者取消了，说：“我不能来看这场比赛了。”
Or David Stern, the NBA commissioner, he actually has four front row seats to every game in the NBA, every night. And there's no way that he can go to every game every night. In fact, a lot of nights he doesn't go to any game.
或者大卫·斯特恩，NBA总裁，他实际上每场比赛都有四个前排座位，每晚都有。他不可能每晚去每场比赛。事实上，很多晚上他一场比赛都不去。
So sometime the day of the game, they'll release those seats. And those four beautiful seats will suddenly become available into the system. So whoever's the first person to phone in, go to a window, or punch in online at that precise second is going to be the one that gets them.
所以比赛当天的某个时候，他们会释放这些座位。那四个漂亮的座位突然就会出现在系统中。所以谁是第一个打电话、走到窗口或在那一秒钟准时在网上预订的人，谁就能得到它们。
So Monet, Monet Joe, what he would do is all night, he would just hang out at his computer, keep pecking, pecking, pecking away, with the Grateful Dead playing and smoking a J and just pecking away, pecking away. Usually it says, "Sorry, your selection is not available." He would peck again, one ticket. He might peck 1,000 times. But then all of a sudden, your screen lights up and gives you that section and row number and says, "Would you like to finish this purchase?" And you know you just made-- you can buy that ticket for face value, which is about as low as you can buy a ticket, and sell it for 10 times that, sometimes.
所以莫奈，莫奈·乔，他会怎么做呢，整晚他都会待在他的电脑前，不停地敲击，伴着感恩而死乐队的音乐，抽着大麻，不停地敲击。通常上面写着：“对不起，您选择的座位不可用。”他会再敲一次，买一张票。他可能会敲1000次。但突然之间，你的屏幕亮了起来，给了你那个区域和排数，并说：“你想完成这次购买吗？”你知道你刚刚……你可以按面值买到那张票，那是你能买到的最低价格，有时可以以10倍的价格卖出。
During the time that you worked, during those five years that you worked as a scalper, how was the money?
在你工作的那五年里，也就是你做黄牛的那段时间，收入如何？
It was pretty phat. It was sick. It was humongous. I had a suitcase of money.
相当丰厚。简直疯了。太庞大了。我有一个装满钱的行李箱。
You had a literal suitcase of money?
你有一个名副其实的装满钱的行李箱？
Yeah. It was actually so much money that I didn't want to deposit it at one time in a bank. I didn't want to freak out the bank manager or anything like that. So I would put a little bit in one bank, a little bit in another bank. And then there was a third bank where I had a safety deposit box. And I would just stuff the cash into the safety deposit box.
是啊。其实钱多到我不想一次存进银行。我不想吓坏银行经理之类的。所以我会在一家银行存一点，在另一家银行存一点。还有第三家银行，我有一个保险箱。我就把现金塞进保险箱里。
The Bulls days, Michael Jordan, were really the golden age of tickets in Chicago. There's always peaks and valleys. And I'm sure Yankees tickets are pretty nice now. Laker tickets are alright. But it was a rare, it wasn't just one sports team having a nice run. It really became something that-- it became the focus of the entire world.
公牛队的时代，迈克尔·乔丹，真的是芝加哥门票的黄金时代。总是有高峰和低谷。我相信洋基队的票现在也不错。湖人队的票也还可以。但这很罕见，不仅仅是一支运动队表现好。它真的变成了……它成为了全世界关注的焦点。
You'd meet people from Sweden and Japan and Korea and England and Germany, and you were like a celebrity to them. You had what everybody else in the world wanted. You had a stack of tickets to the Chicago Bulls game. And people would do anything for them, and they would pay any price.
你会见到来自瑞典、日本、韩国、英国和德国的人，对他们来说你就像名人。你拥有世界上其他人想要的东西。你有一叠芝加哥公牛队比赛的门票。人们为了这些票什么都愿意做，而且他们会支付任何价格。
We felt like we were part of something bigger than us. We felt like we were part of this historical moment. The day Michael Jordan retired in 1998, in June, that's the same day I retired.
我们感觉我们是比我们自身更宏大的一部分。我们感觉我们是这历史时刻的一部分。1998年6月迈克尔·乔丹退役的那天，也是我退役的日子。
Michael Jordan probably sits around with his cousins and friends and talked about his great shots that he made, his game-winning dunks. Some of the ticket people sit around and talk about the great sales that they made for Bulls games. Like, I talked to my friend, John, and he's got a story about it.
迈克尔·乔丹可能和他的表兄弟和朋友坐在一起，谈论他投出的伟大进球，他比赛中的绝杀扣篮。一些卖票的人坐在一起谈论他们在公牛队比赛中完成的伟大交易。比如，我和我的朋友约翰谈过，他也有关于这方面的故事。
An old lady was walking down the street. She passed all the hustlers up. And nobody had thought to ask her. But I was walking down the street, and I just said, "Do anybody have any extra tickets?"
一位老太太走在街上。她经过了所有的拉皮条的人。没人想到要去问她。但我当时走在街上，我只是说：“有人有多余的票吗？”
She said, "Do you need tickets?" I said, "Yeah." And she said, "Yeah, I got a couple of extra tickets, section 111, row 15."
她说：“你需要票吗？”我说：“是的。”她说：“是的，我有两张多余的票，111区，第15排。”
These was the best tickets. These was in center court, 15 rows from the floor. She sold me the tickets at $85 each, which at that time, was face value tickets. I, in turn, didn't even get a chance to walk 10 feet away after I bought the tickets.
这是最好的票。这是中场，距离场地15排。她以每张85美元的价格把票卖给了我，在当时，那是面值票。我呢，甚至还没来得及走开10英尺，在我买票之后。
A whole gang of people got around me. And everybody was bidding on them. When we got finished bidding with those tickets, those tickets sold at $1,200 cash a ticket.
一大群人围住了我。每个人都在竞价。当我们竞价结束时，那些票以每张1200美元的现金卖出。
I was so happy. And the guy that bought them was a Chinese man. Him and his wife went. They thought I was God, because they had the best seats. And I stuffed the money in my pocket and skipped on down the street.
我太高兴了。买下它们的那个人是个中国人。他和他的妻子去了。他们觉得我简直是上帝，因为他们得到了最好的座位。我把钱塞进口袋，一路跳着走下街道。
But that was the most memorable thing. This is what a hustler dream of, of a deal like that, because you hardly ever find a deal like that. You can hardly ever find tickets on a Jordan day. Even if you do a ticket like that, you're going to pay a few hundred dollars for it, and then you're going to run around and try to sell it for big money.
但那是印象最深刻的事情。这就是拉皮条的人梦寐以求的交易，因为你很难遇到那样的交易。在乔丹时代，你几乎找不到票。即使你真的拿到一张那样的票，你也得支付几百美元，然后你要到处跑，试图以大价钱卖掉它。
But to get a deal like that, it just stays with you. There's nothing to say about a deal like that. Bought cheap, sold high, what more can I say?
但能做成那样一笔交易，它会一直留在你记忆里。没什么好说的，那样的交易。低买高卖，我还能说什么呢？
Yeah, well, it's just not like it used to be during the Jordan era. What can I say? It's terrible. It is. It's bad.
是啊，嗯，现在不像乔丹时代那样了。我还能说什么？太糟糕了。就是这样。太差了。
How bad is it?
有多差？
Here, I'll show you. One day, I was at the White Sox, trying to sell tickets, right? And I had this guy that was going to buy a couple tickets from me. And wasn't charging a lot. And it was a $27 ticket. I was going to give it to him for $20 apiece. And a fan walked up and just gave him two tickets. That's how bad it was. And the guy said, "Thanks for talking to me," and went to the ballpark.
给你，我给你看。有一天，我在白袜队比赛现场，试图卖票，对吧？有个家伙要从我这儿买两张票。我没收很多钱。那是一张27美元的票。我本来要以每张20美元的价格卖给他。结果一个粉丝走过来直接给了他两张票。情况就是这么糟糕。那家伙说：“谢谢你跟我说话，”然后就去了球场。
It's a cold, dark, rainy, miserable, February day every day. And it's [INAUDIBLE] now. Where instead of the gleaming bright sun of the Bulls era. It used to be this page had about 30, 40 ads every day in here. Now there's, what, one, two, three, four, five, six. So a lot of people are out of the game that once were in it. It wasn't just me that retired.
每一天都是寒冷、阴暗、潮湿、悲惨的二月天。现在就是这样。而公牛时代则有着闪耀的太阳。以前这张页面每天大约有30、40条广告。现在呢，只有一、二、三、四、五、六条。所以很多人已经退出了这个游戏。不仅仅是我退役了。
Our ticket scalper talked with This American Life producer Alex Blumberg.
我们的票贩子与《美国生活》的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格进行了交谈。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "TWO TICKETS TO PARADISE" BY EDDIE MONEY]
[音乐播放 - 埃迪·莫内的《通往天堂的两张票》]
Coming up, 60,000 Memphis fans can't be wrong about you, can they? In a minute from Public Radio International and Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，6万名孟菲斯粉丝不可能看错你们，是吧？从公共广播国际和芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Middlemen, in which we examine what it means to be the monkey in the middle. We have arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, Stuck Inside of Memphis.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目：中间人，我们将探讨当“中间猴子”意味着什么。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕，第二幕，困在孟菲斯。
A while back, there was a fire in Beth Landau's apartment building in New York. And when the firemen from around the corner were responding to the call, she and her mom, who was visiting, got to talking with one of them, a guy named Sal Princiatta. Sal was a huge Elvis fan. He looks a bit like Elvis. And as fate had it, Beth's mom went to high school in Memphis with Elvis. So there was a lot to talk about.
不久前，贝丝·兰道在纽约的公寓楼里发生了火灾。当附近街区的消防队员赶来响应呼救时，她和正在探访的母亲开始与其中一名叫萨尔·普林西亚塔的队员交谈。萨尔是埃迪·普雷斯利的超级粉丝。他长得有点像埃迪。巧合的是，贝丝的妈妈在孟菲斯和埃迪上同一所高中。所以他们有很多话可以聊。
OK, time passes. After September 11th, Beth checks at the firehouse around the corner to see if Sal is OK. This is one of the units that lost a lot of guys. And it turns out that he survived. He's depressed. Like a lot of firefighters, he developed asthma from digging in the dust and the rubble in the weeks after September 11th, but he is alive.
好了，时间过去了。9月11日之后，贝丝到附近街区的消防站查看萨尔是否还好。这是损失惨重的单位之一。结果他活了下来。他很沮丧。像许多消防员一样，他在9月11日之后的几周里因为挖掘灰尘和瓦砾而患上了哮喘，但他还活着。
She starts dropping by with food for the guys, hanging out. And wanting to do something nice for Sal, she organizes a trip to Memphis for him, to see Graceland. Other firemen from the house get interested in going. And in the end, in May of 2002, 18 of them went as guests of the Memphis Fire Department and many other sponsors, with stops at Al Green's church, all the varied requisite Elvis sights, and an appearance before 60,000 people at the Sunset Symphony on the banks of the Mississippi. And Sal found that for the people of Memphis who they met, he and the other guys were a very particular kind of middleman, a very unusual kind of middleman.
她开始带着食物去探望队员们，在那儿待着。为了给萨尔做点好事，她组织了一次孟菲斯之行，让他去参观雅园。消防站的其他消防员也对此产生了兴趣。最终，在2002年5月，他们18人作为孟菲斯消防局和其他许多赞助商的客人前往孟菲斯，期间参观了阿尔·格林的教堂，所有必需的埃迪相关景点，并在密西西比河畔的日落交响音乐会上出现在6万名观众面前。萨尔发现，对于他们遇到的孟菲斯民众来说，他和队员们成了某种非常特殊的中间人，一种非常不寻常的中间人。
When we arrived into Memphis, as soon as they find out who you are, you're a rock star.
当我们到达孟菲斯时，他们一发现你是谁，你就是摇滚明星。
And now for what you have all been waiting for. We're here to meet the heroes from New York City. These guys are from Engine House 33, Ladder Company 9, which I think is about a mile from the World Trade Center. These were some first guys on the scene, and they lost 10 men out of their 40-man crew. So these are the real heroes of New York City.
现在，为您带来大家期待已久的人物。我们在这里迎接来自纽约市的英雄。这些人来自第33发动机房，第9云梯连，我想这离世贸中心大约一英里。他们是现场的第一批救援人员，40人的团队里牺牲了10人。所以这些是真正的纽约市英雄。
We represent good, you know.
我们代表美好，你知道。
Sal, I'd like for Sal "Elvis" Princiatta to come up.
萨尔，我想请萨尔“埃迪”普林西亚塔上来。
Everybody wishes they could have been there, I think, in one way, for one hour, for one minute. So we connect them to that one minute. It's unnerving. And a lot of the guys feel the same way.
我想，每个人都希望自己能在那儿，在某种意义上，哪怕是一个小时，一分钟。所以我们把他们与那一分钟联系起来。这让人不安。许多队员也有同样的感觉。
It's very unnerving to be applauded. I just can't take it. I appreciate it, but it's unnerving. It's embarrassing.
被鼓掌让人非常不安。我真的受不了。我很感激，但这让人不安。这让人尴尬。
We represent, we are FDNY, and that's what they see. They don't see names, not me, not Pete, not Joe, not anybody. They see what we do.
我们代表，我们是FDNY，这就是他们看到的。他们看不到名字，不是我，不是皮特，不是乔，不是任何人。他们看到的是我们所做的事。
We see, and we know, that we pretty much didn't do anything. I think they feel sorry for us, because we lost the battle, maybe almost pity us. They do pity us. That's pity out there. That's pity treatment.
我们看到，并且我们知道，我们其实什么都没做。我想他们为我们感到难过，因为我们输掉了那场战斗，也许近乎怜悯我们。他们确实怜悯我们。那是怜悯。那是怜悯的对待。
Are y'all friends of those people that died in the World Trade Center?
你们是那些在世贸中心遇难的人的朋友吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I welcome you to Sun Studios, the birthplace of rock and roll. And if you have any questions, hold them until the end of the tour. And if you have any pagers or cell  phones, then turn those off now, because we are entering the year 1950.
欢迎来到太阳录音室，摇滚乐的发源地。如果您有任何问题，请等到参观结束时再提。如果您有任何寻呼机或手机，现在请把它们关掉，因为我们正在进入1950年。
Sun Records was great. The birth of rock and roll, that was a good place to be. That's one part that sticks out in my head a lot.
太阳唱片公司太棒了。摇滚乐的诞生，那是个好地方。那是我脑海中挥之不去的一部分。
Everybody that comes off the tour, I'm going to give y'all one of our short-sleeve t-shirts over here.
每一个参观结束出来的人，我都要送你们一件我们的短袖T恤。
No way, they're getting a short-sleeve t-shirt?
不会吧，他们要送短袖T恤？
Black, white, burgundy, the blue, also in black, and all different style t-shirts. Perfect. Just pick your size, my friend.
黑色、白色、勃艮第红、蓝色，还有黑色，以及各种不同风格的T恤。太完美了。选好你的尺码，我的朋友。
So to take gifts from people, how do I feel? People want to pacify, and want to do what they can.
所以接受人们的礼物，我感觉如何？人们想要安慰，想要尽他们所能。
And so, I present a pair of gold and clausinate cuff links with the city seal.
于是，我送上一对带有城市印章的金色袖扣。
But it's hard to conceive. You're getting gifts while your friends are dead. That's all. How does that equate? What's the purpose?
但很难理解。你的朋友们都死了，你却在收礼物。就是这样。这怎么能等同呢？目的是什么？
These are real heroes. These guys are from New York, World Trade Center.
这些是真正的英雄。这些人来自纽约，世贸中心。
What's up guys, how are you?
怎么了，伙计们，你们好吗？
I've seen a cartoon in the newspaper of Spider-man, Batman, and Superman asking for a firefighter's autograph. And that's just too much to be put on any average joe's back. Because that's really what we are.
我在报纸上看到过一幅漫画，蜘蛛侠、蝙蝠侠和超人在向消防员要签名。这对于任何普通人来说都太沉重了。因为我们真的就是普通人。
And these great guys are here for three days. Let's give them a standing Memphis ovation.
这些伟大的伙计们在这里待了三天。让我们为他们送上孟菲斯的起立鼓掌。
The symphony was pretty cool. I don't really like speaking in public. We were there for the closing ceremonies of Memphis in May. Or was it May in Memphis? I can't remember.
交响乐相当不错。我不太喜欢在公开场合发言。我们在那里参加孟菲斯五月节的闭幕式。还是五月的孟菲斯？我不记得了。
A lot of people get emotional. Maybe they see the pain in our eyes, and for anybody who was ever a soldier, you could tell. They see the look in the eyes. So they feel for us.
很多人会情绪激动。也许他们看到了我们眼中的痛苦，对于任何当过兵的人来说，你就能看出来。他们看到了那样的眼神。所以他们为我们感到难过。
And also, it's their own grief, I would think, that they're letting out. They can't say enough. So they repeat themselves, which is fine.
此外，我想他们是在释放自己的悲伤。他们说不完。所以他们反复重复，这没关系。
I'd like to just shake your hand, bud. Y'all did a hell of a job. And I would
我只想和你握个手，伙计。你们做得很棒。而且我想要
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[嘈杂声]
That's all I can say, is I'm proud. We're really proud of you.
我只能说，我感到骄傲。我们真的为你感到骄傲。
You guys have put us up and made us feel right at home here, very nice of you.
你们让我们住在这里，让我们感觉像在自己家一样，你们太好了。
We're just proud of you, is all I can say. That's all I can say.
我只能说，我们为你感到骄傲。我只能说这些。
Thank you, sir.
谢谢你，先生。
That's all I can tell you is, we're proud of you guys. Y'all did a hell of a job, and we're proud of you, that's all I can say. We're really proud of you. Y'all did a hell of a job, and that's all I can say, bud.
我只能告诉你，我们为你们感到骄傲。你们干得好，我们为你感到骄傲，这就是我能说的。我们真的为你感到骄傲。你们干得好，这就是我能说的，伙计。
We're his connection. We're his connection to what went down. And that's it. We connect him to what went down. And we give him a vehicle to feel it.
我们是他的联系。我们是他与发生过的事情的联系。就是这样。我们把他与发生过的事情联系起来。我们给他一个感受它的载体。
Whereas for you--
而对于你——
Exactly. As for us, we're too connected? No [BLEEP]. Very much too connected.
没错。至于我们，我们联系太紧密了？见鬼的。真的太紧密了。
There was one day we played a softball game against Memphis Fire Department.
有一天我们和孟菲斯消防局打了一场垒球比赛。
Way to go, Sal. Way to come home.
干得好，萨尔。欢迎回家。
[BLEEP].
[脏话]。
All right, whose--
好了，谁的——
Mine.
我的。
You all right?
你还好吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Want me to go get the bottle?
要我去拿瓶子吗？
He's now a paramedic?
他现在是护理人员了？
Something.
差不多。
[SOUND OF INHALER]
[吸入器的声音]
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
I was having a hard time. I dug there a lot of days. That's why my health is so bad. But I was having a real hard time, until I got warmed up.
我当时很难受。我在那儿挖了很多天。这就是为什么我的健康状况这么糟。但在我热身之前，我真的很难受。
If we had our team, if we had our A-team, we would have definitely beat them. Like we have Mike and Dave, who were killed in 9/11. They were great outfielders. If they were there, it's a different game. If Gerarde Baptiste, that's three outfielders. If we had those guys there, we would have picked them apart.
如果我们有我们的团队，如果我们有我们的王牌队伍，我们肯定会打败他们。比如我们有迈克和戴夫，他们在9/11事件中牺牲了。他们是伟大的外场手。如果他们在，比赛结果就不一样了。如果还有杰拉德·巴蒂斯特，那就是三个外场手。如果我们在那儿有那些伙计，我们会把他们彻底击败的。
We lost a lot of guys from the team. And in fact, a recent guy, Gary Guidell, who just took his own life, was on the team. And he was a good guy, Gary.
我们损失了队里的很多伙计。事实上，最近有一个队员，加里·吉德尔，刚刚自杀了，他也在队里。他是个好人，加里。
So I think that's another reason why guys are feeling a little bit vulnerable at this point. Because Gary was a regular joe. He didn't show any signs of hurting any more than any one of us. So that stirred up a lot of fright in a lot of-- in myself. I can speak for myself, but I'm sure I can speak for others, that what happened to Gary is everybody's biggest fear right now, to take your own life.
所以我认为这是队员们此刻感到脆弱的另一个原因。因为加里是个普通人。他没有表现出比我们任何人都更痛苦的迹象。所以这在很多人——我自己心中引起了很多恐惧。我可以代表我自己，但我确信我也可以代表其他人，加里身上发生的事情是每个人现在最大的恐惧，那就是自杀。
Thank you so much for allowing us to be photographed. You make us very proud.
非常感谢你们允许我们拍照。你们让我们感到非常骄傲。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Guys, let's go-- you guys have signed the paper, right?
伙计们，我们走吧——你们签了文件对吧？
You got it.
没问题。
Sal Princiatta. His story was produced with Beth Landau, David van Taylor, and Allie Pomeroy at Lumiere Productions in New York.
萨尔·普林西亚塔。他的故事是由贝丝·兰道、大卫·范·泰勒和艾莉·波梅罗在纽约Lumiere Productions制作的。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "LONELY MAN" BY ELVIS PRESLEY]
[音乐播放 - 埃迪·普雷斯利的《孤独的人》]
Act Three, What It Takes to Tromp Through the Desert. So Moses was this great leader who brought the Israelites out of Egypt. One of the things the Bible says about him is that he was not much of a talker. Whenever he had to give a big speech or tell Pharaoh to let his people go, he would bring along his brother, Aaron, to do the talking for him. This is the story of somebody who's something like that.
第三幕，在沙漠中跋涉需要什么。摩西是带领以色列人走出埃及的伟大领袖。圣经中关于他的一点是，他不善言辞。每当他需要发表重要演讲或告诉法老让他的子民离开时，他都会带上他的兄弟亚伦代为发言。这就是一个像那样的人的故事。
Al Jurczynski is the middleman who is leading hundreds of people who live in New York City to the promised land of Schenectady, New York. And as he would tell you himself, what makes him good at his job is, he is just a normal guy. No flashy speeches. You aren't dazzled by charisma when you meet him. But you trust him.
阿尔·朱琴斯基是一个中间人，他正在带领成百上千住在纽约市的人前往纽约州斯克内克塔迪的应许之地。正如他自己会告诉你的那样，他擅长这份工作的原因是，他只是个普通人。没有华丽的演讲。当你见到他时，你不会被他的魅力所倾倒。但你信任他。
Enough people trust him that he's accomplishing a very unlikely mission. Most of the people who he's convinced to move from the Bronx and Queens are people who immigrated there from the South American country of Guyana. These are people whose ancestors mostly came from India and Africa, moving to an old Rust Belt town of white ethnics. Our producer, Wendy Dorr, went to watch him work.
足够多的人信任他，以至于他正在完成一项非常不可能完成的任务。他劝说从布朗克斯区和皇后区搬离的大多数人，都是从南美国家圭亚那移民到那里的人。这些人是祖先大多来自印度和非洲的人，搬到了一个白人聚集的老锈带城镇。我们的制作人温迪·多尔去观察了他的工作。
Mayor Jurczynski is the sort of politician who's great at talking with old ladies or small businessmen, or really with anybody, for about a minute and a half. But after that, after his opening lines, he goes into this patter. If you hang around him for more than a few hours, you hear the same lines over and over. There are awkward jokes. But he's making such an effort that you kind of forgive him anything. Here he is, showing a busload of Guyanese New Yorkers around Schenectady.
朱琴斯基市长属于那种擅长与老太太或小商贩，或者真的与任何人交谈大约一分半钟的政客。但在那之后，在他开场白之后，他就会进入这种固定的套路。如果你在他身边待超过几个小时，你会听到同样的话一遍又一遍。还有一些尴尬的笑话。但他做出如此努力，以至于你几乎会原谅他所做的一切。这是他带领一车圭亚那裔纽约人参观斯克内克塔迪的情景。
But you know, there's people, Guyanese people, that have come here. And they said, "I've been to Schenectady. It's a little too slow for me. I like the fast pace of New York City." So that's understandable. And I like to tell people that come up here on the bus that if you like traffic jams, you should stay in New York City.
但你知道，有些人，圭亚那人，来到这里。他们说，“我去过斯克内克塔迪。对我来说太慢了。我喜欢纽约市的快节奏。”所以这是可以理解的。我喜欢告诉那些坐车上来的人，如果你喜欢堵车，你就应该待在纽约市。
That was a joke. You know, my jokes are getting pretty old.
那是个笑话。你知道，我的笑话越来越老套了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I know one thing. Whenever I run out of things to say when I'm talking to Guyanese people, all I got to do is mention cricket. And then everybody starts talking.
我知道一件事。每当我和圭亚那人交谈时没话找话，我只要提一下板球就行了。然后每个人都会开始交谈。
He looks around the bus. Nobody starts talking.
他环顾车内。没人开始说话。
In 1995, when he first ran for mayor, Schenectady was going through the same kinds of pains as lots of Rust Belt cities. The biggest employer, General Electric, had downsized from 40,000 employees to just a few thousand. Tens of thousands of people had moved away, or were forced to retire.
1995年，当他第一次竞选市长时，斯克内克塔迪正经历着许多锈带城市同样的痛苦。最大的雇主通用电气公司已经从4万名员工裁员到只剩下几千人。成千上万的人搬走了，或者被迫退休。
For a while, Al Jurczynski had this idea to lure Hasidic Jews to Schenectady. He wanted to repopulate certain problem neighborhoods with a group that was self-reliant, family-oriented, and tightly knit. That idea went nowhere. But then last year, some Guyanese people came to him for help getting an abandoned church for religious services.
有一段时间，阿尔·朱琴斯基想出一个主意，引诱哈西德犹太人搬到斯克内克塔迪。他想用一个自力更生、以家庭为中心、紧密团结的群体来重新填充某些有问题的小区。这个想法没成功。但去年，一些圭亚那人来找他帮忙，想弄到一个废弃的教堂用于宗教服务。
Well, we talked. And I talked about public assistance. And we had had quite a problem with a lot of people coming up from New York City that were not coming up here to work, but were getting on public assistance. A lot of them were doing things that we didn't want them to do, namely get involved in the drug trade.
嗯，我们谈了谈。我谈到了公共援助。我们有很多从纽约市上来的人，他们不是来这里工作的，而是来领取公共救济金的。他们中的很多人在做我们不希望他们做的事，即卷入毒品交易。
And they made it very clear, right up front, within probably the first 5 or 10 minutes that I met with them, that they don't believe in public assistance unless it's absolutely necessary. But it's against their culture to get on public assistance. And I heard that. I was extremely impressed by that. It was just so wonderful and so refreshing. And at that point, that's when I really I started to really embrace them.
他们很明确地表达了立场，在我见到他们的前5到10分钟内，他们不相信公共援助，除非万不得已。但领取公共援助违背了他们的文化。我听进去了。我对此印象非常深刻。这真是太棒了，太让人耳目一新了。就在那时，我开始真正接纳他们。
Thanks, folks, you're in tune to Herman Singh Showtime. It's 93.5 FM on your dial. It's now 20 minutes before 11:00 AM.
感谢各位，你们正在收听赫尔曼·辛格的节目。拨号盘上的93.5兆赫。现在是11点前20分。
And that's where Herman Singh comes in. He's a realtor slash mortgage broker slash weekly radio host down in New York City, in the Queens neighborhood where most Guyanese live. It was his bright idea to bus Guyanese up to Schenectady every Saturday, to encourage them to buy houses up there. He pays for the buses himself, and promotes the trip like crazy on his weekly real estate slash music program, Herman Singh Showtime.
这就是赫尔曼·辛格介入的地方。他是房地产经纪人兼抵押贷款经纪人兼每周电台主持人，在大多数圭亚那人居住的皇后区。他有个好主意，每周六用巴士把圭亚那人送到斯克内克塔迪，鼓励他们在那儿买房子。他自己掏钱支付巴士费用，并在这个名为《赫尔曼·辛格秀》的每周房地产兼音乐节目中疯狂宣传这次旅行。
If you're planning to purchase a property in Schenectady, our next trip is actually going up to Schenectady on Saturday. And room with friends, if you are selling your property--
如果您正计划在斯克内克塔迪购买房产，我们下一次行程实际上是在周六去斯克内克塔迪。和朋友住在一起，如果您要出售您的房产——
At the beginning of the mayor's initiative to bring Guyanese to Schenectady five months ago, the mayor went on Herman's radio show and gave out his personal cell phone number on the air, a political gesture he explains this way.
在五个月前市长启动引进圭亚那人到斯克内克塔迪的计划之初，市长上了赫尔曼的电台节目，并在广播中公布了他的个人手机号码，这是一种政治姿态，他这样解释。
I have free incoming calls. So if I was paying for the incoming calls, I wouldn't have done it. And I'd do it again.
我有免费的入站电话。所以如果我要支付入站电话费，我就不会这么做了。我会再做一次。
He gives me a sheepish look, and then blurts--
他羞涩地看了我一眼，然后脱口而出——
857-4000, area code 518. If you want to buy a home in Schenectady, give me a call.
857-4000，区号518。如果你想在斯克内克塔迪买房，给我打个电话。
One Saturday in December, I schlep out to Queens at 6:30 in the morning to take the bus tour myself. And while two dozen of us wait for the bus to arrive, I meet Ali Latif. He's 60 years old, and he's been living in the Bronx with his wife for the last 14 years. His black hair is perfectly parted on one side. And he's wearing a clean Oxford shirt buttoned to the collar.
12月的某个周六，我清晨6点半拖着身子去皇后区参加巴士之旅。当咱们二十几个人等着巴士到达时，我遇到了阿里·拉蒂夫。他60岁了，过去14年一直和妻子住在布朗克斯。他乌黑的头发分得很整齐。他穿着一件领口扣好的干净牛津衬衫。
He tells me that he works as a doorman in Manhattan. And since he had to miss a day of work to come on the trip, and because he missed the bus by five minutes the week before, the trip is actually costing him $260. To be sure he doesn't miss the bus again, he's been waiting here since 5:30 this morning.
他告诉我他在曼哈顿做门卫。由于他不得不请一天假来参加这次旅行，而且前一周他晚到了5分钟错过了巴士，这次旅行实际上让他损失了260美元。为了确保不再错过巴士，他从今天凌晨5点半就一直在这儿等着。
And when he starts talking about why he's thinking of moving to Schenectady, he repeats over and over, his voice raised, pointing his long, thin finger at my nose, that he's not on a joy ride. He's a serious businessman, looking for an opportunity.
当他开始谈论为什么考虑搬到斯克内克塔迪时，他一遍又一遍地重复，声音提高了，用他细长的手指指着我的鼻子，说他不是来兜风的。他是个严肃的商人，在寻找机会。
So I lose two day's pay just to go check this place out. It means that I'm not joking. $260 are losing, right?
所以我损失了两天的工资只是为了去看看那个地方。这意味着我不是在开玩笑。损失了260美元，对吧？
I am going here on business. I am personally going here on business. I am a serious chap. That is what I'm saying. I don't make joke with business.
我是去做生意的。我亲自去那里做生意。我是一个严肃的人。这就是我所说的。我不拿生意开玩笑。
It's a three-hour bus ride to Schenectady. And when we pull into town, it's not pretty. We pass abandoned gas stations and empty store fronts and ugly, rundown apartment buildings. And then, in the middle of nothing, is City Hall. And City Hall is spectacular, obviously just renovated with gleaming marble, the kind of old government building that's so beautiful, that the thought crosses your mind, "Maybe I should work in government."
去斯克内克塔迪有三个小时的车程。当我们进入城镇时，景象并不美好。我们经过废弃的加油站、空荡荡的店面和丑陋、破旧的公寓楼。然后，在荒凉的中间，是市政厅。市政厅非常壮观，显然刚装修过，闪闪发光的大理石，那种古老的政府大楼，太漂亮了，以至于你脑海中闪过一个念头，“也许我应该在政府工作。”
And there, lined up in front as our bus pulls up, are a chorus of clean, perky white men in multi-colored golf shirts.
当我们的大巴停下时，在前面排成一排的是一队穿着色彩鲜艳高尔夫衫、整洁、活泼的白人。
It's a long way, isn't it?
路很远，对吧？
We've got beautiful weather for you here today, if nothing else, huh? Good morning. You have a nice ride up? These are the important guys with the food, right? Come on up.
今天这里天气不错，如果说还有什么值得庆幸的话，对吧？早上好。旅途愉快吗？这些是带着食物的重要人物，对吧？上来吧。
We are led like little, sleepy sheep into an intimidating-looking room with leather chairs lining the perimeter. Everybody looks a little scared. Ali, the serious businessman who is not on a joy ride, picks a seat close to the front.
我们像一群昏昏欲睡的小绵羊被带进了一个令人望而生畏的房间，房间四周排满了皮椅。每个人看起来都有点害怕。阿里，那个不是来兜风的严肃商人，选了个靠前的位置坐下。
Good morning. I want to welcome you. It's my job to talk a little bit about the general economy, the history of Schenectady. Schenectady was founded about 300 years ago as a Dutch trading settlement.
早上好。我想欢迎大家。我的工作是谈谈斯克内克塔迪的一般经济和历史。斯克内克塔迪大约是在300年前作为荷兰贸易定居点建立的。
This speech, by the city's Director of Economic Development, pretty much sets the tone for what's to follow all day, mind-numbingly boring facts, which go on and on and on, peppered with the kinds of utterly sincere-sounding appeals that you almost never hear from any government official, anywhere.
市经济发展局局长的这次演讲，基本上奠定了接下来一整天的基调：令人头昏脑胀的无聊事实，接连不断，其中穿插着那种你几乎永远不会从任何政府官员那里听到的、听起来极其真诚的呼吁。
--because quite frankly, you're a great opportunity for us. And please know that we want you and need you. And so we hope you find us as much of an opportunity as we find you.
——因为坦率地说，你们对我们来说是一个巨大的机会。请相信我们想要你们，也需要你们。所以我们希望你们像我们看待你们一样，看待我们也同样是一个机会。
One by one, the men take the stage, the head of the Chamber of Commerce, a state legislator, the president of one of the local hospitals, and the guy who owns the Goodyear Family Tire Center.
男人们一个个走上台，商会会长、州议员、当地一家医院的院长，还有古德伊尔家庭轮胎中心的老板。
So it truly is a very, very exciting time to be a small person in downtown Schenectady.
所以，作为一名小人物生活在斯克内克塔迪市中心，确实是一个非常非常令人兴奋的时刻。
The Guyanese seem to find all of this captivating. A few of them are taking notes, and everyone is alert and attentive. Ali explains to me later, they're immigrants. No official of the United States government has ever courted them like this.
圭亚那人似乎觉得这一切都很引人入胜。其中几个人在做笔记，每个人都很警觉和专注。阿里后来向我解释，他们是移民。美国政府没有任何官员曾经这样追求过他们。
They didn't welcome me in that way when I reached America in 1988. They didn't tell me anything about, I welcome you because you're a hard-working man, Guyanese people. But Schenectady actually, Schenectady is crying for help. And the only people who can put Schenectady back on its foot is the Guyanese people.
1988年我到达美国时，他们并没有那样欢迎我。他们没告诉我任何关于我欢迎你们是因为你们是努力工作的圭亚那人的话。但斯克内克塔迪实际上，斯克内克塔迪正在哭喊着寻求帮助。唯一能让斯克内克塔迪站起来的人就是圭亚那人。
It's true. It's not false. They're hard-working, and they're going to make it if they're going to put back the city on its foot.
这是真的。不是假的。他们很勤奋，如果他们能让这座城市重新站起来，他们会成功的。
Which brings us to Mayor Al, who orchestrated this whole morning to get them to see it this way. He's the last speaker. And when he comes on, more than anyone else, he treats the Guyanese like they're special. He solicits them in a way that seems more genuine.
这就引出了阿尔市长，他策划了这整个早晨，让他们以这种方式看待它。他是最后一位发言者。当他上台时，他比任何人都更把圭亚那人当作特别的客人对待。他以一种看起来更真诚的方式招揽他们。
Just in a couple minutes, I just want to tell you, Schenectady is a beautiful city. and I'm going to pass some cards out, too. If you want to just take one and pass it around.
只需要几分钟，我只想告诉你们，斯克内克塔迪是一座美丽的城市。我还要发一些名片。如果你们想拿一张就传着看看。
He hands around a stack of his own business cards, which people seem a little shocked to be getting. And then, to make them feel welcome, he says in various ways, I am like you. He talks about his own immigrant roots, about how his grandparents came over from Poland, and about how his wife's parents moved to Schenectady from Italy.
他递出一叠自己的名片，人们似乎有点惊讶会收到这些。然后，为了让他们感到受欢迎，他以各种方式说，我像你们一样。他谈到自己移民的根源，谈到他的祖父母是如何从波兰过来的，以及他妻子的父母是如何从意大利搬到斯克内克塔迪的。
And there's a lot of similarities between Italians and Guyanese. They're very family-oriented. They're very ambitious. It's not uncommon for the Italians to work the way the Guyanese work.
意大利人和圭亚那人有很多相似之处。他们都非常以家庭为中心。他们都很有野心。意大利人像圭亚那人那样工作是很常见的。
I think you're a lot like Polish people, my family, in that you're very reserved. Italians like to argue. I know because my wife is Italian.
我认为你们很像波兰人，像我的家人，因为你们非常内敛。意大利人喜欢争论。我知道这一点，因为我妻子是意大利人。
The mayor's bus tour of town takes four hours. He shows us good neighborhoods and bad, the sewage treatment plant and the old GE plant. We even stop at his son's Little League picnic in the park for half an hour, because he promised his wife he'd drop by.
市长的城镇巴士之旅花了四个小时。他带我们看好坏街区，污水处理厂和老通用电气厂。我们甚至在公园里停留了半小时，参加他儿子的小联盟野餐，因为他答应妻子会顺道去看看。
Hey, Tom. Hey, Tom.
嘿，汤姆。嘿，汤姆。
And he's constantly dragging the citizens of Schenectady onto the bus for testimonials. Tom is a city councilman who happened to be working in his front yard. We also meet Eddie, another city employee, and Jewel, the secretary to the former mayor. And around two hours into the tour, we're driving down a long, narrow street, when Mayor Al spots a Guyanese family outside a house. I can see the mayor just about restrain himself from pointing excitedly at them.
他不断把斯克内克塔迪的市民拉上巴士来做证明。汤姆是一位恰好在前院工作的市议员。我们还见了艾迪，另一位市政府员工，还有朱厄尔，前任市长的秘书。在旅行大约两个小时后，我们沿着一条狭窄的长街行驶，阿尔市长在房子外面发现了一户圭亚那家庭。我能看到市长几乎在克制自己，不要兴奋地指着他们。
Well, just tell everybody what you think of Schenectady.
好吧，告诉大家你觉得斯克内克塔迪怎么样。
Very nice place to live.
是一个很好的居住地方。
The last stop on the tour is the one that closes the deal for a lot of people. The mayor takes us to his wife's parents' house. Next to a small white ranch home is a huge vegetable garden, with the most beautiful vegetables I think I have ever seen in my life. It strikes a chord with everyone. The mayor's in-laws, an elderly Sicilian couple, make a point of greeting each people and shaking their hand.
旅行的最后一站是让许多人成交的那一站。市长带我们去了他岳父母家。在一座小型白色牧场风格住宅旁边，是一个巨大的蔬菜园，有我这辈子见过的最漂亮的蔬菜。这触动了每个人的心弦。市长的姻亲，一对年迈的西西里夫妇，特意问候每个人并与他们握手。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[嘈杂声]
They offer us all some homemade wine, and we're all goners, including Rohini and Gandhi Gopi, two New York City public school teachers who were skeptical after the morning presentation.
他们请我们所有人喝自制的葡萄酒，我们都被俘虏了，包括罗希尼和甘地·戈皮，两名纽约市公立学校教师，他们在早上的介绍会后还持怀疑态度。
When I see this, it reminds me of my own vegetable garden. And to my mind, this is the best part of the trip.
当我看到这个时，让我想起了我自己的菜园。在我看来，这是这次旅行中最棒的部分。
So now, how are you feeling about Schenectady?
所以现在，你对斯克内克塔迪感觉如何？
More and more positive.
越来越积极了。
We want to get, we want to start making steps, if we could talk to somebody today about certain steps of making a move.
我们想，如果我们今天能和某人谈谈关于搬家的具体步骤，我们想开始采取行动。
We stand around in the driveway, drinking sweet white wine out of plastic cups. When I check in on Ali, he's unbuttoned the top button of his shirt and feeling a little tipsy, and making plans to buy a house plus an empty lot next door.
我们站在车道上，用塑料杯喝着甜白葡萄酒。当我查看阿里时，他解开了衬衫最上面的扣子，感觉有点微醺，正在计划买一栋房子加上隔壁的一块空地。
It's a month after the bus trip, and I'm back up in Schenectady. There's an old bar called Sark's in Hamilton Hill, which is the neighborhood that the mayor wants all the Guyanese to move to. You could say it's the worst neighborhood in the city, or you could say it's where the best house bargains are, depending on your point of view.
巴士旅行一个月后，我又回到了斯克内克塔迪。汉密尔顿山有一家老酒吧叫萨克斯，那是市长想让所有圭亚那人搬去的社区。你可以说那是城里最糟糕的社区，或者你可以说那是房产最划算的地方，取决于你的观点。
When you drive through it, it seems like a third of the houses are boarded up, a sketchy enough place that people in the bar are kind of surprised that I would be walking in there alone. I talk to a guy named Rod Smith. He's a carpenter, and he grew up here. And though he and his friends don't think much of the mayor, they like this one initiative. Nearly everyone I meet in Schenectady likes it.
当你开车经过时，似乎三分之一的房子都用木板封起来了，这是一个相当危险的地方，以至于酒吧里的人对我独自走进去感到有点惊讶。我和一个叫罗德·史密斯的家伙谈过。他是个木匠，在这儿长大。虽然他和朋友们对市长没什么好感，但他们喜欢这个计划。我在斯克内克塔迪遇到的几乎每个人都喜欢它。
Anything to upgrade this community would be 100%. Schenectady is in the dumper right now. I can't make from my car to my front door, which is 15 feet away, without somebody trying to sell me something. I have people running up and down in front of my windows all night long, selling drugs and other things.
升级这个社区的一切都是100%好的。斯克内克塔迪现在处于谷底。我从车到我的前门，那15英尺的路程，不能不遇到有人试图向我兜售东西。整晚都有人在我的窗户前跑来跑去，卖毒品和其他东西。
I got a guy standing outside of my front door, trying to sell drugs. And he thinks that I'm pulling over to buy something from him. And I said "I live here. Get away from my front door." Next thing I know, they're going to be coming through it. I don't want that.
有个家伙站在我的前门外试图卖毒品。他以为我靠边停车是要从他那儿买东西。我说“我就住这儿。离我的前门远点。”接下来我怕他们要闯进来了。我可不想要那样。
All the Guyanese believe it's safer in Schenectady than in New York City. But they're moving to the worst neighborhood in town, and the crime stats aren't encouraging. In the year 2000, Schenectady county had half the violent crimes per capita than Queens county had. But there were so many property crimes that overall, Schenectady had much higher crime rates per capita than Queens.
所有的圭亚那人都相信在斯克内克塔迪比在纽约市安全。但他们正搬到城里最糟糕的社区，犯罪统计数据并不令人鼓舞。2000年，斯克内克塔迪县的人均暴力犯罪率只有皇后区的一半。但那里的财产犯罪太多，总的来说，斯克内克塔迪的人均犯罪率远高于皇后区。
Not that this makes much difference to the Guyanese I talk to. Whenever I ask them about the difficulties of moving, how dangerous the neighborhood is, the availability of jobs, the fact that Schenectady gets 60 inches of snow a year, so they're not going to actually get that much time in their gardens, they shrug it off. They say what I imagine immigrants to this city have always said. They say they're ready to sacrifice, which is one reason the mayor's pitch seems to work so well.
并不是说这对我和我交谈的圭亚那人有什么影响。每当我问他们搬迁的困难、社区有多危险、就业机会、斯克内克塔迪一年降雪60英寸（所以他们实际上不会在花园里花那么多时间）等事实时，他们都耸耸肩。他们说了我想象中搬到这个城市的移民一直说的话。他们说他们准备好做出牺牲，这也是市长的推销策略似乎如此有效的原因之一。
He doesn't tell them it's going to be easy in Schenectady. He makes it clear it's going to be hard, and they're going to have to work hard. And they all tell me, that's exactly what they're prepared to do.
他没告诉他们斯克内克塔迪会很轻松。他明确表示这会很艰难，他们必须努力工作。他们都告诉我，这正是他们准备好要做的。
This house, look at it. The driveway is very wide. Right? It's very spacious, wide. It's not choked up--
这房子，看看它。车道非常宽。对吧？非常宽敞，开阔。没有堵塞——
When I catch up with Ali, he shows me a Polaroid of the yellow house he now owns in Schenectady. Two weeks after our bus trip, he took another day off from work, bought a $70 bus ticket, and went up to see some houses. He liked this one immediately. He didn't have the place inspected or do any more research about Schenectady or the neighborhood. And compared to prices in New York City, it was a steal. He paid $55,000, all cash.
当我见到阿里时，他给我看了他现在在斯克内克塔迪拥有的那栋黄色房子的宝丽来照片。在我们巴士旅行两周后，他又请了一天假，买了张70美元的车票，上去看了几栋房子。他立刻就看中了这一栋。他没有让人去检查那个地方，也没有做更多关于斯克内克塔迪或那个社区的调查。相比纽约市的价格，这简直是抢到了。他花了55000美元，全是现金。
The house is profit, because people--
房子是有利的，因为人们——
It's a two-family house, and there are two tenants in the building. The tenants are section eight, which means that the government pays a large portion of the rent. He'll rent it out for two years, and then he'll move to Schenectady to retire. He's put his faith and his life savings into this plan. And it was all because of the mayor, he tells me, the way the mayor treated him.
这是一栋双户住宅，楼里有两个租户。租户是第八节援助对象，这意味着政府支付大部分租金。他会把房子出租两年，然后他会搬到斯克内克塔迪退休。他把他的信念和他一生的积蓄都投在了这个计划上。这一切都是因为市长，他告诉我，是因为市长对待他的方式。
I think one, why I'm going to live here, I can approach him. That's a most important factor. I can't go approach Mr. Bush and Rudy Giuliani and the governor.
我想第一，我为什么要去那里住，因为我可以接近他。这是一个最重要的因素。我不能接近布什先生和鲁迪·朱利安尼还有州长。
I can't well meet them. It's hard to reach them. But I can reach, if I live in Schenectady, I could go and reach the mayor. And I am sure they would listen to me.
我很难见到他们。很难接触到他们。但如果我住在斯克内克塔迪，我就能接近，我就能去找市长。而且我敢肯定他们会听我的。
These are people that are from Guyana originally--
这些人最初是来自圭亚那的——
Again, Mayor Al.
又是阿尔市长。
--but for the last 10 or 15 years, have been in New York City. And in New York City, they revere the office of mayor. The mayor of New York City is an international figure. So when they come here, oftentimes they'll say, "I've never shaken the hand of a mayor before." And I go along with that. I let them think that I'm bigger than life.
——但在过去的10到15年里，他们一直在纽约市。而在纽约市，他们崇拜市长这个职位。纽约市市长是一个国际人物。所以当他们来到这里时，他们经常会说，“我以前从没和市长握过手。”我就顺着他们说。我让他们觉得我是一个了不起的人物。
He says this is completely different from the way his regular constituents greet him. It's a hard, blue-collar city, he says. The old residents don't put the mayor up on a pedestal. Only the new residents do that, which is a mixed blessing for him, since he's not the sort of person who feels very comfortable on a pedestal.
他说这与他的普通选民欢迎他的方式完全不同。他说，这是一座艰难的蓝领城市。老居民不会把市长放在神坛上。只有新居民才会那样做，这对他是种混合的祝福，因为他不是那种在神坛上感觉很自在的人。
Wendy Dorr. As best as anybody knows, there were about 1,000 Guyanese in Schenectady before the mayor started his initiative in May. And according to mortgage brokers, perhaps 200 families, maybe 1,000 people have moved since then. The mayor's goal is to triple the Guyanese community to 3,000 people by the end of the year. His long-term goal is a little more ambitious, 35,000 people by the end of three years, a huge increase for a city of 60,000. So far it's a small enough change that everybody that Wendy talked to in Schenectady, even in the neighborhood that is most affected, told her they did not notice a change yet.
温迪·多尔。据所知，在市长5月份启动计划之前，斯克内克塔迪大约有1000名圭亚那人。据抵押贷款经纪人说，从那时起可能有200个家庭，也许1000人已经搬过来了。市长的目标是在今年年底将圭亚那社区增加到3000人。他的长期目标更有野心一点，三年内达到35000人，这对一个6万人的城市来说是巨大的增长。到目前为止，变化还很小，温迪在斯克内克塔迪采访的每个人，即使是在受影响最严重的社区，也告诉她他们还没有感觉到变化。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "MOSES SUPPOSES" BY GENE KELLY AND DONALD O'CONNOR]
[音乐播放 - 基因·凯利和唐纳德·奥康纳的《摩西假设》]
Well, our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, Starlee Kine, and Mr. Chris Neary. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Jane Golembiski. Music help today from Agoraphone. Our website, where you can listen to our programs for free or order tapes, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
好了，我们的节目今天由温迪·多尔和我自己，以及亚历克斯·布隆伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦、斯塔莉·凯恩和克里斯·尼里先生共同制作。高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。 Todd Bachmann和Jane Golembiski提供制作协助。 Agoraphone提供音乐协助。我们的网站，您可以在那里免费收听我们的节目或订购磁带，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who would like to thank all the listeners who recently pledged.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他想感谢所有最近承诺捐款的听众。
I did make it a rule to see how much money they had in their wallet. And I was going to take all of it.
我确实制定了一条规则，看看他们钱包里有多少钱。我要把钱全拿走。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "MOSES SUPPOSES" BY GENE KELLY AND DONALD O'CONNOR]
[音乐播放 - 基因·凯利和唐纳德·奥康纳的《摩西假设》]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。